all right uh
i watched the low basketball over the
weekend and now that west virginia is
out i will not be watching any more but
in honor of marge madness there were
three double-digit seeds in the sweet 16
number one illinois lost to number eight
loyola yada yada biggest upsets of the
2020 nfl season in honor of march
madness chris you've got this like don't
they look at the people like who seated
the tournament after a day like the
weekend like this and go maybe we didn't
see things the right way maybe it's not
the right maybe we don't know what they
don't know
they never know right well usually they
know with the number one and number two
seed this year was like i don't think
you do know actually um okay so this is
let's say johnny west virginia all right
let's see if you're a true one west
virginia has reached the ncaa tournament
final once it was back in 1959. back in
your day
where they want to walk for a mile to
get some milk
despite losing the championship what
mountaineer was named the tournament mvp
lost a cow by a point right i know that
i assume it's jerry west well i mean of
course
you should assume it i mean it's like
can we give like are we serious with
these questions with him
uh testing him with what what color is
blue again
that's what we're doing
damn i mean you got
ah all right go ahead florio
all right uh plenty of upsets from last
year to choose from i got to start with
the game that uh really stunned me more
than anyone and it was the
the new york jets
just a week right after having their
victory snatched away
yeah two weeks it was two weeks after
they got the victory they got the
victory they had their wait they were
going to beat the raiders and they let
the helmet raiders then they got killed
by the seahawks
i was trying to find a way to blame that
on gruden right no the jets actually
lost that game yeah but then when we had
written them off and they were closing
in on going 0-16 they somehow beat the
la rams that was the upset of the year
yeah 23-20 right like their defense
smothered uh you know and it was the
rams it wasn't some they made it to the
playoffs oh they made it to the final
eight i feel like that was the game
where i think was the the official
whammy to the jared goffera and the rams
i think i feel like that was the game
where it was a little like
okay
that enough is enough like are you
kidding me and that was the i feel like
the changing of the narrative from there
i think that was the shocker of the year
i think it's hard hard not to pick that
one all right
you know my next one i think is the 11-0
steelers
you know being upset on what night was
that i forget a monday night or is that
a it was an early monday game that game
either way late in the year 11-0
steelers tuesday it was a tuesday
against a washington football team who
we were going oh the defense is pretty
good but they're not going to be able to
beat the steelers and they just kept
hanging around and hanging around had
the goal line stand alex smith got hot
and really the steelers were never the
same after that game it was like a
season changer for them kind of
everybody like i took them off the pedal
pedal stool
and knocked down to where everybody
thought
everybody thought we could beat these
guys so that to me was probably the
second biggest shocker of the year
yeah there are several on my list
involving the steelers but that was the
first one where finally after weeks of
teetering they did get knocked off the
pedal stool um i got to go giant
seahawks i got i got plenty of others
but giant seahawks that was i'm just
trying to remember the reaction where
we're like what why are you kidding me
the giants went to seattle and beat this
seahawks team mccoy
yeah yeah daniel jones not even playing
in that game and they they made russell
wilson look ordinary and you know that
may be one of the the games that
contributes to whatever the the current
ranker is in seattle
involving what they really think of
wilson and how much of the offense
they're going to let him run but uh that
that was a stunner to me as well both
new york teams congratulations they got
something that they can brag about they
their teams they were so bad this year
that they they could give us wins over
nfc west teams that would that would
make it to the top of this list well
they certainly played tough at the end
of the year both the new york teams and
the other giants that that was a shocker
you know no nobody saw that they just
they physically beat up the seahawks
which was was the shocker their defense
played good they ran the ball in the
second half on them all right oh i'm a
little i'm not sure where to go with
this one
you know i know i think i am gonna go
the wild card game i'm gonna go brown
steelers you know again i know these are
two play-off teams so it's like not a
shocking upset
but
it was the steelers at home and i think
it was the look of the upset altogether
and the fact that yeah the steelers we
expect them to win and the browns is the
browns as juju said and all that you
just thought okay the steelers are fine
some way this is their little step
brother and they'll find a way to beat
them up but then it's 28 nothing before
you even blink an eye i mean i think
that's part of why it was such a
shocking upset too it wasn't the fact
that hey they beat him it was the fact
that we got into the second quarter and
we were like oh this game's kind of over
it's i don't this this offense with
pittsburgh they're not going to come
back from this this kind of deficit so i
think that was one of the shocking
upsets of the year for me
and ben roethlisberger over 500 passing
yards only the second time in postseason
history at quarterbacks had 500 more
yards in a game and those quarterbacks
are now owen two tom brady was the other
one now tom brady's were part of a game
that was back and forth this was
steelers are down 28 nothing so it's
throw throw throw throw throw all game
long which explains why ben got to 500
yards all right i'm surprised you didn't
go with this one the only game i know
the regular season that the chiefs lost
that they tried to win and that was to
the raiders and they went that long
stretch with no losses at all and uh
uh
for the raiders to go in there and do
what they did it's still in hindsight it
just shows the only way you're gonna
beat the chiefs
is well no the the bucks rewrote the
script before super bowl 55 the only way
to beat the chiefs was outscore them the
buccaneers have introduced a new wrinkle
to that which is uh you know rush the
passer relentlessly to the point where
they hardly score any points yeah well
good luck you got to have uh four
awesome players and the defensive line
for everybody to you know emulate that
one so you know the buck's got a special
damn team but you're right i know i was
sure i wasn't sure what to do there with
picking that game i almost picked that
football game all right my last one i
think i'm gonna go with the eagles and
jalen hurts beating the saints you know
coming to town late in the football year
that was a shocker to me you just
thought man the eagles jalen hurts the
way he throws the football they're not
going to beat this great new orleans
saints team and there they were what up
17 nothing in the first half that was
one of the shockers of the year for me
two quick other ones on the way out the
bengals over the steelers on that monday
night game late in the year with ryan
finley at quarterback and in hindsight
all the way back into week one how did
the jaguars beat the colts how did they
pull it off we didn't realize it was an
upset at the time
by the end of the season holy crap the
jaguars beat the colts
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports